welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by natalie
chapman who is a senior consultant at
sterling warrington
natalie's personal vision is to inspire
her twin daughters to be strong females
by showing them what is possible to be a
woman with a career whilst being a great
and fantastic mom
i think this vision says it all with
what all of you need to know about
natalie and her mindset
after a long and successful career in
hospitality natalie started her career
in recruitment over 16 years ago and
hasn't looked back since
natalie recruits in the building and
material sector recruiting sales and
marketing professionals she loves the
sector she loves learning about her
industry and most of all she loves
providing an outstanding service to all
of her clients and candidates natalie
welcome to the podcast
and thank you for inviting me
really excited for this
and uh as i was just telling you before
we started where where we'd like to
start this podcast is is the million
pound question
so i'd love to hear your take
so we'd really love to hear sort of your
thoughts and ideas on what you believe
are the characteristics and traits that
really make up a high-performing
recruiter in today's market
so i think more than anything is having
a personality i don't believe that you
have to come
with a certain skill set i think if you
have a personality if you like talking
to people
if you genuinely are naturally
inquisitive
you know i was two years old and walking
up to you know granny's in the
line for the supermarket going what's
your name where'd you come from you know
how long you've been waiting there i
think if you're naturally a people
person where you like talking to people
because recruitment all that
that is all it is
is talking to your candidates finding
out what's best for them talking to your
clients and finding out what they best
need so if you are naturally good at
talking to people and and finding out
about them you match the two together
and you know recruitment has come a long
way in the last 16 years with training
with onboarding with different ways of
working
so you know to me
the other thing is a really strong
mindset you know
recruitment is a roller coaster it's not
easy there is a lot easier ways of
making money
and giving yourself you know less things
to worry about you know a lot of what
you do isn't down just to what you do
it's down to what other people want to
do
so you have to be able to kind of brush
that off and you have to pick yourself
up you know the next day is a new day a
new challenge
and you've got to have that mindset of
that you know
you want to go on that journey
because it is forever ups and downs and
you know even after 16 years
some days i have bad days
and i i you know and i think to myself
have i done everything possible that i
could have done to save that fee yes i
have but it was just the person didn't
get the job or they decided to stay
where they was so you know mindset and
being naturally inquisitive everything
else
i know from the businesses i've worked
in everything else can be taught
yeah i love that and i know we we
know
well and truly about that riley i mean
this podcast used to be called the
recruitment roller coaster that's that's
what uh
it began as because
as you said i i was very much on that
roller coaster and i think everyone
listening to this
is continues to be regardless of how
experienced they are right
so
i think where where i would i'd love to
start so there's so many different
things that we can go into here in in
the last 16 years
but there's just a couple of key things
that i really want us to focus on i mean
the first thing
like just just for sort of everyone's
benefit like before we do this podcast i
typically have a conversation with the
guest and we just talk a bit about what
we're going to talk about in these
things and i asked um nat to send over
an email just around some of the her key
milestones in her career because
sometimes
as you can imagine when you've been in
recruitment for 16 years it can be quite
difficult to
for me to ask you like oh tell me about
the first deal you did or whatever to
sort of jump straight back in that
moment so i asked natalie to send me
over some some sort of key milestones
and some key things about her and her
career and her journey today
and yeah that that vision was at the top
of that email which i absolutely loved
so i wouldn't i wanted to start there if
we uh if we may i guess like where where
did this sort of where did this
obviously vision come from i get it
would have happened after you had your
children obviously uh because they're
part of it but i guess why do you feel
it's important to have one is what i'm
asking and when did you establish this
i think for me there's there's several
factors to my vision okay the first one
was is you know i was brought up by a
single mom that did everything to make
sure that me and my twin sister
had everything that we possibly could
but she couldn't afford a lot
so you know i didn't have the fancy
holidays when i was a kid i didn't have
you know we had to save up our own
pocket money if we wanted the latest
trainers
so when i decided to have children i
wanted to be able to provide for my kids
to give them the life that
i didn't have
but i also wanted to show them
that as a strong female
you don't have to rely on somebody else
to bring that in you can do that for
yourself and for me not saying that my
husband doesn't contribute because he
does but it's about it's about showing
my daughters their own independence
about
being happy in what they're doing it's
not just about the money it's about them
being strong they're being independent
not having to you know because a job is
a man's job you know you should ask a
man to do it no you know we were setting
up the christmas tree together the three
of us and my husband got really annoyed
at it and was like i can't do this blah
blah blah i love the lights and i said
come on girls let's work on this
together
because we are strong independent women
and we can fix the christmas tree we
don't need your dad to do that so when
he tried to come and help them put the
christmas tree down my chloe turns who's
minnie me and says dad it's fine you sit
down we've got this we're strong
independent women
i think
uh they just turned 11 last week oh wow
amazing
so for me i think it's about
it's about putting
away the past for me to make sure that
i i know that i'm doing right by my
daughters not just with money and and
and the things i didn't have but with
that time and with getting involved with
the school and you know i've just taken
one of my daughters to an adhd process
which was a lot of time and investment
but i want to show them that yes i can
earn well
and bring the extra money into the house
but i also
can give them that time i can show them
that juggling act of being both is
possible
don't get me wrong i have lists upon
lists i have personal lists i have work
lists i have this going on but i know i
can do them them both and i'm lucky that
my kids are very
happy that i can do both you know i
changed my hours when they started
school so i work really long hours on a
monday tuesday wednesday and i work
until half two on a thursday and friday
so i can go and pick them up from school
take them to their clubs and classes
but also in recruitment i'm on my phone
or if i've got wi-fi i've got my laptop
on i can be watching them at a
gymnastics class or a football club and
still be working and half there and half
with them and being able to juggle it
i love that no i think i think it's
amazing i think
there's just something so obviously you
hear it in the business context and like
personal development world like i think
there's something so powerful about
really crystallizing that vision and
seeing it writing it down saying it to
yourself because i think in particular
in the recruitment world there's always
there's always so many
things going on you can be pulled in so
many different directions and sometimes
you could sort of you can lose that
grasp of like why am i doing this or
things fall out or things don't go your
way and you can ask that question can't
you why the hell am i doing this and i
think when you've sort of crystallized
that that vision
of yours and you've really got a bit of
a north star or you really understand
why you're doing what you're doing it's
just a great anchor point
yeah i've really had to do some work on
that for myself with my own sort of
professional journey and that's always
helped and it's just a really good thing
to think about but i guess as you were
sharing that i was just curious
i know you said that your mum um brought
you up but obviously
like you're yeah really committed to
becoming the best possible role model
for for your children but who was your
role model obviously your mum but i
don't know who who
i don't know is part of it because maybe
you didn't have as much of that as you
was growing up or
it was
i think
i think
from a young age i was always pushed
into hospitality because i'm a natural
people person yeah
and when um
when my mom passed away my mum passed
away about 17 years ago so similar
around the time i got into
um the construction industry and she was
a real strong woman she was helping
people not like i do but she went and
was helping the bushman people over in
namibia help them create their own um
their own education their own
local
communities bringing money back in
themselves and supporting themselves
and i did a lot of projects out there
with her and i've seen what difference
she made
so to me
my mom i know it sounds really cheesy
but my mom is this strong independent
woman that walked away from my dad my
parents split up when i was eight or
nine she walked away and said you know
what we're we're a team we can do this
together
um and that's what i say to my kids even
though you know my husband is is around
um and we're all together you know we're
team chapman you know we work together
we work as
as a team
to make you know life better my husband
works full-time i work full-time the
kids are obviously at school
um and we have to make the best of the
time that we have together to work
together so and my mum taught me that
from a very young age you know my
friends was out you know
going off and just hanging around the
streets and we had chores to do and we
had jobs to do and you know we had to be
part of that because my mum couldn't do
it all on her own and i think that
installed in me
that thing of teamwork and helping each
other out and
you know that's what i bring into a
business now so yeah my mum is 100 my
role model even though she is she's not
with us you know god rest her soul
she's she's installed in me a really
strong
work ethic and and drive and ambition
to be knowing that she's looking down at
me thinking you know what wow mine
that's really made it that's amazing i
love that so much
so let's sort of i guess use this this
conversation of
role models and i guess bring it into
like the professional recruitment world
so like how i don't know sort of how you
would how you how you feel about this
but i think i was telling you when we
spoke before i think um
one of the the challenges in recruitment
is definitely a lack of female role
models uh who are in senior positions or
where i don't know maybe um natalie
who's 21 years old hasn't got the sort
of natalie chapman who you are today to
look up to um and sort of be inspired by
and motivated by within the recruitment
office or recruitment environment
i think i told you some of the
conversations we've had in the past when
we focused on diversity and recruitment
and more women in recruitment and
leadership positions
i do feel like it is sort of slowly but
surely changing but when i've
interviewed people on here in the past
it really feels like um
women had the sort of option or choice
really where they had the crossroads of
like do i start sort of a family and
then put my career on hold and sort of
maybe try and come back to that um and
sort of women weren't necessarily always
supported with that journey which meant
they'd worked really hard maybe got to a
leadership position went on maternity
leave had a family and then just found
it really difficult to then get to that
sort of leadership position again which
has maybe had a real knock-on effect on
the amount of women in leadership
positions and there's almost his
crossroads of like
do i sort of sacrifice having a family
early on and just really double down on
my career and these things so i guess to
transition it into
sort of women leadership and being
inspired and having role models like
how
two questions really one did you have
role models in the recruitment world and
did that help you and then two how can
we go about cultivating and
creating more sort of um role models
like yourself the younger females of
women could look up to and be inspired
by motivated by
i think
the the answer to the first one is is i
met in my
first part of being in recruitment a
whole load of
women that i didn't want to be like
really
yeah yeah fair enough
that were
they were money grabbing they was all
about them it was oh no i don't want to
be a part of that i'm too busy darling
you know i need to
for me
and
that made me very clear on what i did
want to be like so okay
one of the things that i'm
um no matter where i've worked
any rookies that are coming forward
anybody that's joining our business even
though i'm not a manager i like to be
part of the mentoring leader team to
actually
give that wisdom help people fall down
less of those potholes that i would have
gone through in the beginning of my
career but also i mean i do a session
for our new starters and graduates on
mindset
on vision boarding and
i've had a lot of training from a lot of
different people over 16 years and i've
kind of cherry cherry-picked all the
bits that i like that has worked
and and i kind of help and get involved
in training so for me it's about
it's about
not necessarily looking up to other
people people look at me
and they'll be like
i want to be like that but i've taken 16
years to get where i am so i actually
say to people
utilize all the bits of good things i
say or good things i do or the
motivation or the mindfulness stuff i do
but figure out your own thing and your
own vision and everything else
and to people coming in i think
i don't think that women have to put
the child in the career
in in a box it doesn't have to be one or
the other nowadays you know i had
i had my daughters in
2011
um i'm a natural people person so five
months off of them was more than enough
and i was ready to come back to work
because i wanted to talk to people that
would communicate back with me
um
but
with a desk as long as you're in a good
business
somebody will babysit your desk for you
and look after it and cultivate your
clients and then you take it back or if
you want to do part-time or something
different when you come back from having
a baby because obviously kids are
expensive to put in child care then you
still can do that you know there's other
roles that you can do while you're
you know growing that little human into
a little person yeah you know like you
could come i've had people come back and
do resourcing because they want to stay
in it they want to stay in touch but
they do want to give their focus their
child so whatever business you're in
just give that give those options see
what they can do for you at the end of
the day if you're a
person adding value to the business
and you're given a return you you can
move forward and then obviously when you
know kids start school and different
things then you can look at going up
that that food chain as well but it's
one of those businesses
when you are starting out and having a
child and obviously you've got those
massive amounts of costs of going to
um nursery i mean just to come back when
i first came back to work in 2011 it was
costing me 1500 pounds a month to send
my twin daughters to
to to nursery so for me
i had to earn the commission otherwise
there was no point me going to work
you know so there is that
you know because there is that earning
potential in recruitment you can do both
and i think it's just about having
courageous conversations to really
figure out what's right for you every
single mom is different and it's not
until you hold that baby in your arms
that you understand if you know
the balancing act that you want to take
let's just talk about they should talk
about this for a second so the
courageous conversations
because because i'm sure it can be a
really daunting and like difficult time
as well as
finding your feet of being a mother for
the first time and these types of things
you've then
got this sort of new environment of like
oh like i've now got to talk to my
employer about having time off and
what's my future role going to like
what's my future my the business that
i've worked really hard at like these
things so i guess i don't know what
would your what would your advice be for
anyone that like um
is in the process or is needing to have
those courageous conversations i don't
know if there's anything that maybe you
could have given advice to yourself
going into those things it seems like
you would have been quite comfortable
having those courageous conversations
but not everyone is i don't know what
advice you could give anyone
to be fair for me um i always knew i
wanted to come back work full-time
because as you can see from my vision
it's really important that i've got me
and but my boss didn't believe even till
the week i started having my keeping in
touch days that i was going to come back
full time he was like i didn't believe
it was going to happen yeah so i think
i think take the pressure out of it you
know you take your maternity leave you
keep in contact with your employer you
can do keeping in touch days which you
get paid for which just what's that talk
to you a bit about that that's that
might be not good
everyone knows
so keeping in touch days basically i
mean this is when i was having my kids
so it might be slightly different now
it was five days that you could get paid
for on top of your maternity leave to go
back into work to do a full day's work
to see how you feel obviously you've got
to get the kids ready get them to
nursery blah blah blah but just see how
you feel before you decide what your
role looks like moving forward when you
go back into work
did that really help
i i had a day away from two people i
couldn't communicate with i make myself
sound like such one of these ones but
i think one of my motivations is is i
need to be nat you know i need that to
show my kids the best
version of myself and
and ultimately when i was at home on my
own with two babies with one pair of
hands
where
i couldn't do
all the mother and baby classes i
couldn't even go and get them weighed
because tommy took one of them the other
one was crying and then it wasn't
so for me
so for me i was like five months i said
to my husband we've got the money there
to start getting him into nursery let's
just do it because otherwise you're
going to come and see home every night
seeing me in a puddle on the floor
i'll deal with it and he was like nat
you being happy makes the kids happy so
we'll just have to figure it out
yeah i love that
so look let's talk about let's talk
about this mindset journey i guess the
question i sort of write down to try and
talk a bit about this because when when
we spoke before this that that after our
quiz just yeah i think i absolutely love
your mindset and i think it's
i think it's brilliant so i think the
question that i had was like how
how have you can continue to sort of
reinvent yourself
um and and gone about not i guess what i
put down here this doesn't come across
the wrong the wrong way but like getting
lost with the quote-unquote times you
know because i feel like
where you are on your career journey you
could be quite easily like i don't know
i just feel like you could quite easily
be like i know like other people are
getting beyond me or they're younger
than me i don't know i just like how
have you continued to reinvent yourself
and not have that mindset that sometimes
people can fall into you know i hope
that doesn't come across effectively no
no no no but i am the female version of
people peter pan and i'm not growing up
you know at the end of the day
you know i am as crazy and as out there
my kids will tell you you know ages but
a number my body tastes a bit different
but that's another story so
for me i think
every time
um
every year especially probably since the
girls have been born i've tried to
invest in me
and and that and that doesn't
necessarily mean um
going out and buying a new wardrobe
although sometimes it does involve that
um but it's about
about being true to yourself it's about
understanding your flaws or your areas
of of weakness
um
and sometimes it's about taking a really
strong hard look at what other people
see
and when i started this probably
eight or nine years ago
i thought everyone saw me as bubbly nat
that was out there and was you know a
bit mad and really loud and everything
but some people saw it as probably a
little bit i know it all and a little
bit aggressive and
and i'm not that i ever meant it to come
across like that
but i think some people because i am
quite
i am quite out there some people was a
bit um intimidated by it sure so
um i had a couple of clients that was
trying to put um people that had placed
their three management programs and one
of it was to do was coaching so they
said they needed to coach someone from
outside of the business to get this
qualification so
and this person knew me so we started
talking and it was a really just open
forum
and
and then
because there has been so much
probably where that anger and that
intimidation comes from from my past and
as you know childhood stuff
i probably had more to work through than
than what i realized
so um i started and paying out for it
all totally myself i had hypnosis
i've had
um spiritual therapy which is really
good for like uncovering those
childhood little clinks that you don't
realize that you're holding on to or
yeah that you're holding on to etc and
i also um have had some cbt therapy
just making sure that i've got the tools
when i feel myself getting triggered or
really angry
um
there's a certain breathing techniques
and and stuff i do and i write myself
to-do list so i don't get overwhelmed
etcetera
and
and for me i i listen to quite a lot of
um
hypnosis so i go sleep most nights
listening to one of my many hypnosis um
apps um
that allow me to just one have a really
great night's sleep so i think
everything's better when you've set well
absolutely um
but also just
subconsciously working on
on my mindset and also
showing the girls that having that
positive mindset and looking things so
they they have to give me um on a
whatsapp group we have they have to give
me their three positives of the day
so each day yeah before they go to bed
they have to do three positives a day
because then you're hunting for you're
hunting for the positives you're not
you're not letting those negative
vibrations allow you to to get hold of
you
yeah yeah i love that song oh yeah so
they have to watch at me every night
before bed
what's the uh what's the what's that
group called
it's it's just okay they have a separate
one i've got katy positive and chloe
positive okay i thought you're gonna be
like the chapman
superheroes or something like that or
something
[Laughter]
i love it no thank you so much for
sharing that and
i find that so interesting right just a
really quick anecdote just from
something i experienced and i find that
so interesting around investing in
yourself
because
um a couple of years ago i went to a
meditation retreat
and i was
i was i was the only guy there and then
the the rest of the people there was
about 10 or 12 of us the rest of the
people there were were all women and
they were all parents
and there's a number of things that we
did like we for like a day and a half we
didn't speak
um there's a couple a couple of other
like things that we did uh throughout
the sort of two free days that were
there and there's a bunch of exercises
that we did
and there was a number of like
meditations that we did around gratitude
and
how we feel about ourselves and just
really sort of trying to make the space
to look at ourselves like you said have
a good hard look at yourself
and i always always remember this
because it was a room full of mums and
parents and when we were sharing after
one of the exercises around what came up
for you and like what you struggle with
these things
like ev what everyone shared was
these women really felt like they
stopped loving themselves or they
stopped making space to invest in
themselves after like their sort of
quote-unquote children or family didn't
rely on them anymore because their
purpose was very much
make sure the kids are okay
and then when they've sort of now
they're on their own journey they're
sort of a bit lost around like yeah like
making time for themselves invest in
themselves loving themselves so i just
wanted to share that because i think
that's amazing that you you did that i
really believe that if you would have
really honest conversations with
other mums out there that that might be
something they've quite struggled with
where like if they're obviously children
have grown up and they may have sort of
lost attach to that that purpose if you
go i don't know if that makes sense but
that was that that was something i
always remember because i feel like my
mum has struggled with this a bit and
i've tried to help her with it and spoke
to her about it
i think it is and also you know i told
you on our first conversation you know
i've started going through early
menopause so for me
having that strength of mind as men
where a lot of women start doubting
themselves because your body changes
your mind isn't as sharp etc you know
there's all these weird and wonderful
things happening to you
you can start doubting yourself you can
start believing that you're not worthy
or you know that things are happening
but because i've strengthened you know
there is so many things that have
happened in my life that could have sent
me down a tunnel of darkness despair but
because i've spent so much time
investing in my mind
of to be the strongest version it could
possibly can
and still to this day i'm still working
when it's we're not a finished article
yeah it's non-stop it's non-stop yeah
yeah but
yeah i know that's what's kept me strong
that's what kept me up there instead of
down there
yeah i love that so much so let's i
guess let's just break this down a bit
then because i know this is super
important to you like what
with like maybe the recruitment context
like i think clearly like i think that's
evident considering how long you've your
career has been in recruitment right
because everyone listening here knows
the roller coaster know the highs know
the lows and as i'm sure you've
experienced and still experience now
like the the low days in recruitment can
be really [ __ ] light and can be
really difficult to swallow
so guess what what are the sort of
day-to-day weekly non-negotiables for
that
that you do to really make sure that
like you said you don't sort of go down
that tunnel of negativity or that tunnel
of um yeah not believing in yourself
what are some of the non-negotiables
that you did to really help with your
mindset and daily habits or weekly
habits that you do to help with this
so i think planning and preparation is
key and
the thing with recruitment as i think if
you're if you're billing a considerable
amount i think it's really difficult to
fit that in eight to five or whatever
hours you work yeah so i always give
myself just a little bit of time
doing my more admin tasks or more
searchy tasks
and or things on linkedin and stuff that
i do while i'm watching telly the kids
are in bed they're i'm they're not
losing any of my time my husband's you
know listening to something on his phone
he's not over that interest in what i'm
doing
so
i always try and do that for a couple of
evenings a week just to get myself ahead
of the game and just make sure at the
moment candidates are really tough to
find to make sure i've got enough people
to call
um
and then i always just make sure that
each week i don't set myself numbers to
hit
i set myself
goals to hit that were around the
numbers i know what my conversions are
inside out about the front and where i
need to increase my conversions
so for me it's about
knowing what i want to achieve
so at the moment i've got so many jobs
on so i will put how many people against
each of my jobs that i need to get over
to that client i will then
you know put certain jobs that i know i
can get to offer that week how many
interviews i want to arrange working out
on i know my conversions on cv center
interview
so
to me i think it's really um
uninspiring to walk up to a board on a
monday morning and say
oh i'm gonna get three jobs on i'm going
to make 10 bd calls i'm going to do
because at the end of the day they're
just mindless numbers
and i i can't personally work like that
this is what is on my to-do list this is
what by friday i want to achieve to go
home and say do you know what
i've smashed it this week and there are
physical things to happen
that i can influence
that i can make happen
give us an example then like what your
goals this week
so um in fact i'm going to talk to you
about last week's because i actually
okay lately i just smashed it out
that way all right that's something
you're saying come on
so um
i said last week because i've got so
many jobs at them and i just need
candidates and i wanted to feel there
was five or six roles that i had to have
to get to interview yeah because
otherwise people are going to start
getting stressed at me now the most
interviews i have ever arranged in a
week in 16 years
just 18 interviews in a week
mega
last week
how many 25 20 20 20. nice
love that so um for me i went home with
a massive sense of achievement i'd be in
the 17-year
yeah
best and obviously you know we all know
in recruitment that interviews make
placements and placements make money and
prizes so
um i know that my pipeline is really
strong you know coming through into this
this this quarter and into next quarter
so
i just always look at what
what has to happen
you know
my boss will come up to me and they were
like
bdbdbd and i'm like yeah but you know
because i've been doing it for so long
yeah i can make five calls and get five
jobs on
but if i haven't got the capacity
to handle that five jobs on and i'm
gonna let five people down i won't make
the bd calls i know how to develop my
pipeline so he likes to you know and i
just say to him look back in your box
i'll sort it out don't find that i know
when my pipeline's low and i'll put the
phone up and yeah if it's if it's
how it is at the moment would double the
amount of jobs i should have on then let
me fill them because that's what makes
us money
i love it so let's talk about this
challenge that everyone is dealing with
right now i've had a couple of messages
around this so
and obviously you've been you've been in
the industry for some time to be
interested to get your thoughts so like
how
how are you dealing with so you said
you've got loads of jobs on
you need more candidates so obviously
safe to say
the sort of supply demand issue is
really on the candidate side at the
moment so i think we can all assume that
candidates have probably got more choice
than they ever had and also their
current employers are probably should be
aware if if they're not sort of naive
and understand how the current market is
but are also probably doing everything
they possibly can
to keep their people because they know
how much it's going to cost and the time
and the
implement and the challenges sorry of
like what could happen if they don't get
that person back in and these things so
how
like how are you navigating that
challenge at the moment in the sense of
i could speak to not a candidate in my
market we build a relationship i feel
like we've got a good commitment but
like you could have a lot of jobs on the
table and you could quite easily take
the job or things could fall through i
could accept account like how are you
dealing with all these challenges right
now like what what are you thinking day
in day out at the moment to have to make
sure you're not being ghosted to make
sure counteroffers aren't being accepted
even though they can be obviously
sometimes but i don't know what's top of
mind for you what are you doing
so i think a lot of recruiters and i've
been very mindful of this over the years
go in and they start selling to somebody
oh i've got the greatest job in the
world
whereas i don't do that
okay i start a conversation
whether i found that person on one of
the back of the job boards whether
they've applied for a job whether
they've messaged me on linkedin whether
i've messaged them on you know
recruiting professional whatever it is
i do not sell a job i listen first what
is your situation what are your
frustrations what is the things you love
about your job what are the things you'd
hate if you could hand carve that next
job
what would it look like to you what
would it need you to do to enjoy mondays
so once you have that information you're
in a position of power because if they
say they hate new business and i've got
a new business role i'm not going to
tell them about it you know if they say
well hank have this role and it's
exactly what i've got and it's right for
them in their personal circumstance then
i'll tell them about the job and the
detail i go in that i know about my
clients
is like i work there
okay you know it's not a job spec that
i'm reading off i've been down i've
visited the site i've understood the
management structure i've understood the
opportunities i've understood what that
role gives to that person
so so for me
it's about doing finding all the
different elements that can work at the
minute and making sure you've got access
to all the job boards um
linkedin or you know getting all of
those
web crawlers and everything and getting
everyone into a long list making sure
that you've got the facility to email
everyone to say something text them
phone them because you've probably got
five or seven touch points before you
get hold of somebody at the moment so
anything that makes your life easier be
available to talk to people out of hours
because ultimately they don't need that
job right now
you know this is on their terms not on
your terms
and when you do build a relationship
with people you know i've told some
woman that i've placed today that my
kids have got these debit cards at 11
years old go henry that they can use in
shops because she's a mum that's going
to go that's going to make her life
easier
and if you befriend people and they
understand
it from you know that i'm a working mum
myself they're less likely to ghost you
i think in the last two or three years
if i've had two or three people go to me
even those people that have let me down
and not took jobs
they won't ghost me they won't just they
will come back to me because i've built
a relationship i think
the people that make recruitment
transactional
yeah
and just want to make a placement
um and they do it all on numbers they're
the people that are struggling
to get those people over the line at the
moment because you have to build
relationships you have to
you have to identify what that person
needs
how how can we how can we get people to
open up then because i think that that's
also a challenge right so yes i need to
like i think let's be honest if you're
listening to this right now if you look
at i don't know the last five candidates
that you've registered like and your
manager was to ask you okay now what are
their drivers
like what like you said what is their
dream next role
like if you listen to this and you don't
know the answer that question you're
going to struggle right it can't be
oh well like they said if i can get them
a 10 grand pay rise that'd be buzzing
it's got to be more than that right yeah
so i guess but obviously part of that
means that i've got to be really good
at not having spoken to that before or
we haven't really got a relationship
before and get you to open up about
those drivers and what's important to
you so i don't know like how how can
people get better at like how can we get
people to open up i don't know what's
your thoughts on that
it's about i ask an open question so i
will start um you know michael with you
you're a new client you know hi you know
my name's nat i'm calling from stan in
warrington i found your details on on
this job board i have got many
opportunities in your local area but
what's really important to me is to
understand what your next opportunity
looks like to you and i know that might
be different from the other recruiters
you spoke about you spoke to however i
want to listen i want to understand it's
now a good time to do that if not i can
book a time and it's more convenient
yeah yeah and then what and then what
what what
what do we talk about then when i'm
going look now i'm really busy these
recruiters have sent me job specs they
they're just they're they're just
getting me going like i've i've got jobs
like no i've just good luck good night
okay i'm not gonna i know that sounds
really precious but no no no no
no that's great waste my time for
somebody that's not serious about moving
on because they will let me down they
will let my clients yeah yeah right yeah
and if i've if they say to me i can't
talk right now and i can hear this stuff
going on i'll say look i've got your
email address here i do want to talk to
you there's several things i want to
talk to you about
i'm going to email you tell me when's
good for you and i'll call you back at
that time
yeah i love it i think that's that's
great i think that that's really useful
for people
so i think the other part to this which
you've mentioned
is
truly working with committed clients
and businesses hiring managers that you
really understand
so let's just flip this on its head then
so like what what's nat's mindset and
approach to
obviously
gaining more commitment from clients who
again could really just say hey nat look
i'm working i've got this other agency
on there they only spoke to me briefly
i've given them the job spec they're now
getting me cvs look can we can we just
keep this brief
like how how can people listen to this
like start like getting a lot more
client commitment which is super
important in increasing the placements
and that fillability as well
so for me i just say to them if they're
prepared to give me one hour
investment at the front end of the
process
that one hour investment of their time
will pay dividend through the life of
our um our relationships
if they're not prepared
to put that one-hour investment they're
not a client i want and they're not
somewhere i want to send hard-to-find
candidates yeah and would you say that
would you say that in a more
professional way
yeah well i'd say in a direct way as
well
depending on the client because at the
end of the day
people see recruitment as a necessary
evil yeah whereas i am not just
recruitment i am a value added service
to their
business yeah absolutely and if they
can't see that
then they're not somebody i want to work
with i don't want loads of clients
i want key clients that want to give me
multiple roles and for me to help
the culture you know the investment in
their business the right people that are
all from the message from the md all the
way down to the internal salesperson so
for me
if they let me in they see the benefit
of having that on their side whereas
if not but i think that does come again
from mindset so yeah
you know i don't believe because they're
a sales director
that they're any better than me in fact
i probably earned the same money as them
you know so and i have far less
responsibility than they do so
who's the cleverer
but for me i don't think because it's
you know a guy in his 50s or 60s that's
been doing it for 20 years he's more
important than me or i don't think that
because they've got a certain job title
that that they know it all yeah you
don't you know i i yeah no i work with a
lot of clients and and the value and
stuff that i can bring of what other
people are doing you know i won't just
offer them recruitment i'll go in and
i'll do time emotion studies i'll talk
to their sales people to find out what's
going on you know for me i i get a
better understanding of how their
internal sales team works but for them
i'm adding value so for me it's
it it's about
knowing your own self-worth
when i first started here there was a
new
there was a client i was trying to get
in with so i've helped their major
competitor for years
grow from being a five million pound
business to a 35 million pound and i'd
placed internal sales people at every
one of these new branches
so i phoned up this guy i you know went
to do my pitch and he was like your
recruitment i don't want to talk to you
right he was about to put the phone down
excuse me i've got something really
important to tell you about growing your
business and being the same size as x
business
is that not something you want to hear
and he was like i'm so sorry
love it and adam was like how did you
get away with that i said well he was
going to put the phone down on me anyway
it was you know
yeah
no i don't no but i think what i take
from that is what you're talking about
is
no i'm not just another recruiter who's
telling you about specific candidate you
didn't even mention anything about a
candidate you're saying hey
do you want to be like this business who
they should know
i've helped them achieve that this
should be important to you is it not
right
and look people
people will people way more driven by
decisions about what they could lose
rather than what they would gain
and at the end of the day i've done
nothing with him but i wasn't going to
let it go
without a fight you know at the end of
the day you know
i get a lot of i get a lot of business
because of how long i've been doing it
through referrals yeah okay so i i will
i will automatically say when i've made
a placement who else do you know or i'll
go through their linkedin see that
they're connected to the people i want
it so i do very little cold business now
it's all more networking but
for me
just go in and i say the same to my
daughters they get fearful of a
headmaster well he goes toilet the same
way your dad does girls
i love it so what do you expect to to
wrap this up then on this point
where where do you so for recruiters
that the um may be struggling with this
right now and there will be a lot of
people when i'm me struggling this right
now when i mean like they might be
getting a lot of candidates to maybe
towards that final stage and things are
falling through
like where do you see people go wrong
with this then on on the candidate side
and they're experiencing a bit more
dropouts deals falling through because i
think that can that can be happening a
lot right now with how crazy the market
is where where are the typical areas
that you would encourage them to look at
or consider improving so when you um
when you go to offer a candidate a job
reconfirm in writing
yeah
why this job is the right opportunity
don't just put salary in package all the
extras the working hours the flexibility
the working from home the progression
all of those things that you've had
conversations with put it into writing
reconfirm talk it talk that through with
them in person don't just send it
and then also you know give them some
information about counter offers because
a lot of people take counter offers six
months down the line
you know they've
you know that they've
um they've gone back again or you know
they want to be looking and and don't be
frightened to make a joke with somebody
let them go and have that they're still
a candidate for six months time 12
months time you know i know they've let
you down then but don't cut your nose
despite your face i had one guy that
didn't want to go forward for my job
offer last week and i said to him and he
says you're the only one that's not
tried to talk me into this
and i said no i said but i do want you
to change my number in my name in your
phone he says what do i change your name
to i says well change it to i told you
so and follow me back
i love that um so
but
don't just think a lot of recruiters
think about that target here and now now
yeah yeah and don't think about that
think about that that person will
recommend you to three other people
because you've handled it right that
they'll come back to you again in 12
months time
so just think about
doing right by people and people will do
right by you
i love that
well as we come to an end here then i
guess just find a couple of questions
so one for anyone listen to this that
might sort of i'm sure they'll they'll
feel inspired they'd love your energy
your approach to mindset
i think there'll be people out there
that want to have more of a mindset that
you've spoken about but find themselves
having more of the days where they might
be focusing on the negatives a bit too
much and they should but they know they
should have a bit more of that energy
and that mindset so what like what
advice would you give to those people
that want to cultivate more of that that
mindset which hopefully like you said
will help them be better equipped to
look at the positives or focus on the
things that can hopefully help them
improve and learn rather than being
dragged down by that deal not going in
or the negatives or that client call how
it went terribly you know what would
your advice be for them so two things
that are free
spend 10 to 15 minutes every day on
youtube watching something around
mindfulness law of attraction just get
into the habit of filling
10 minutes of your day with positivity
and the second thing is on instagram and
facebook there's loads of law of
attraction or mindfulness groups go and
join them all and then your news feed
gets filled with positive quotes
positive videos etc and they're they're
free they're easy for everyone to use
and that's how i started my journey just
filling my day with more of the positive
vibrations rather than negative ones
i love that and i think it can be we can
so easily be filled with
the negative right now
so and i think one of the ways that this
can be influencing us without realizing
is who we're following who are engaging
with
so i love that tip
that's that's brilliant
um
so what what's what does the future look
like for you then what are you excited
about this year are we gonna break are
we gonna break the interview record this
week what will you expect we're gonna
break
um
target that i i built for the year so
what billings overall building a target
yeah yeah i think it was my first year
being at sterling warrington last year
and obviously i had confidences and
things yeah i'm competing right yeah
um so to get where i got last year was
it a great year no was it a lot more
than adam thought i could
joining you know a new business after
being so long another one yes
but for me i want to get back to that
levels again and
from where my where my sort of pipeline
is and what people have really told me
they're looking at this year um it's
definitely just definitely possible so
yeah i'd like to do that and just and
just say that you know after 13 and a
half years been at the last company yeah
um to say you know that i can do it and
that i can build it back up myself and
it's actually down to me not down to
anybody else that's quite important for
my mindset
love it now it's been an absolute
pleasure i think you're an inspiration
absolutely love your energy i love your
mindset keep being you
and um thank you so much for joining us
on on the podcast
oh you're more than welcome it's been a
pleasure